foreign
I thought she was a nice one I said I
didn't want shrimp if I was allergic I
could have died
our people have been through a war a
mosquito Uprising a low-rise gene
tripped now right now we have peace the
stove stole my baby let me go she'll
stop at nothing to destroy us
under your bow
no no no by my calculations the wall
could be frozen over in two months I'm
sure whatever you saw it's probably
nothing this is the wall
nothing
you have to get Kesley back she's the
symbol of sisto's power that's the only
way to stop the madness
under bow
I'm cursed everyone who follows me gets
eaten or blown up
we must Slaughter every one of them but
some could still see the lights no Jesse
spoke to me she wants them all dead
my flock our worst fears were realized
strike down those who wish us harm the
wall will be United under Jessie's bow
or our only hope
everyone in the wall is going to die
because of you
for Jesse's lives
foreign